i guess this is like a chasing letter as
well isn't it yeah so the debts are like
a black cloud
that's super amazing that went really
bad it was like a one
shot man just overwhelmed i did think
that paul would be a bit further than
where we are already just like
banging our head against the walls and
to he's like
upset with me the hardest one i've done
man
we basically failed the financial
freedom challenge
back to the drawing board you're looking
to buy some houses folks yeah
you might recognize jordan from the tv
yep onto the next one i don't know
manchester at all he's not doing any
deals in manchester before
i think this could be a little bit
harder than we bargained for these
agents
are not having it now that's a little
bit what
when you ring they don't answer
when you go in they're rude
come on there was me thinking manchester
would be a friendly place
it's falling through oh i'm excited
about that
sounds sweet i'm getting a bit excited
now
oh [ __ ] oh man
i just had someone crash into me on to
the next viewing
we're in the middle of a pandemic
everything's closed
we just had a car crash but nothing's
going to stop us can't stop won't stop
debt free to prioritize just filthy rich
this is unlike any financial freedom
challenge i've ever done
let's try the next place this is going
to be
massive we've seen so many zeros you see
people
attempting entry who would come to this
bungalow in the middle of the night who
needs to book a viewing where you can
just
turn back terrible a rebellious property
under the name
i think i've taught you a little bit too
well though mate
it's not the financial freedom challenge
it's the become a developer
from nothing challenge like this is the
dream